paris à quelques encablures de la place
de l'étoile il est 13 heures ce dimanche
zoom qui m'arrive au pas de course sous
le joug des chanteurs lyriques dans la
chorale de l'église anglicane st georges
mais aujourd'hui il est arrivé un peu
trop tôt à
l'heure à quelqu'un qui a les clés
shujun à 34 ans coréen il est né au sud
du 38e parallèle qui marque la
séparation depuis 1945 entre les deux
corées marié deux enfants il est arrivé
à paris il y a quatre ans attirés par le
prestige de la scène lyrique française
l'investissement personnel de toulouse
pour son église c'est sa façon à lui de
se rapprocher du pays il manque quelque
chose des déchets des corps n
comment dire la télé et film
donc oui on parle de ça aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on parle je pars pas
beaucoup sous le joug ne parle pas
beaucoup heureusement il chante bien
depuis sa création il ya dix ans un
choral est devenu un pilier de l'église
où la parole de dieu se récite en
harmoniques
on aime chanter ouais surtout douai dieu
oui chez les sud-coréens prier n'est pas
une affaire de génération les chrétiens
rassemble 40 % de la population et leur
nombre ne cesse de croître même les plus
jeunes font résonner leurs mélodies
cateau pop fidèles à leur paroisse il
donne à l'église un petit air de mjc
indépendamment de la partie religieuse
il ya quand même une
genre de communauté qui
qui s'organisent en fait autour d'eux de
l'église
et notamment le dimanche ça permet de
nous retrouver
tous entre nous et c'est non seulement
important mais mettrait en dire est
utile après la joie des retrouvailles
l'hebdomadaire l'ambiance devient vite
solennel comme au karaoké la bonne
parole est inscrite sur le mur
[Musique]
dans ce pays d'asie la foi ne connaît
pas la crise
[Musique]
mais
l'église ça sert aussi à ça serrer des
mains et se serrer les coudes un
dimanche habituel pour l'une des 14
églises sud-coréenne de paris
ce matin tout jaune a rendez vous avec
une jambe bien amis sud-coréen devant
l'opéra bastille yu zhang un premier
ténor dans les coeurs de la célèbre
institution parisienne il ya dix ans il
fut même le premier sud-coréen à
rejoindre l'opéra national sous le joug
ne lui rêverait de l'imiter alors le
petit café c'est l'occasion de partager
les bons tuyaux
de nous les tripes à la spécialiste
pendant l'audition je vais vue
et puis je me rappelle bien de nuit
voilà à oui il ya plein de correa l'a
donc oui peut-être moi aussi je peux
travailler un peu il y a dix sud coréens
dans les choeurs de l'opéra bastille 10
% de l'effectif total en corée du sud
chanter est une véritable religion du
coup à paris les musiciens d'excellence
représente dignement la diaspora
[Musique]
la répétition est terminée avant
d'entrer en scène yu zhang prend
toujours le temps de méditer au milieu
des partitions son livre de chevet oui
ça voilà c'est juste avant le spectacle
je lis je lis à la bible et
je suis aussi chrétien près très près et
après complètement partie traitée comme
pratiquant il faut dépêcher après
quelques prières yu zhang rejoint la
scène ce soir il conduira les choeurs de
tabarot du triptyque de puccini devant
plus de 2700 spectateurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
17e arrondissement tout le jun participe
ce soir à un concert pour la paix la
corée du nord et celles du sud sont
séparés par un rideau de fer
impénétrables du coup le champ sérieux
et parfois même la politique
en corée du nord en est dictateur de
père en fils depuis quelques semaines
kim jong il le cher leader prépare sa
succession un passage de témoin qui fait
ressurgir des espoirs de paix maintes
fois avortés ouais en ce moment il ya un
changement de petites artères la a donc
ouais c'est le bon moment je crois le
concert
[Musique]
à l'entrée de la salle il y a fool les
sud coréens de paris se sentent
concernés par le changement politique du
pays voisin le frère ennemi la corée du
nord
pour claude juneau le directeur du
centre culturel coréen paris c'est à ses
compatriotes qu'incombe la
responsabilité de la réconciliation
dans la communauté coréenne ici en
france on pense à nos
à nos amis de la corée du nord qui se
font et film
on souhaite la réconciliation pour la
politique
de corrèze est bon c'est une grande part
notre souhait de la paix dans la
péninsule
pendant ce temps tout le jun a rejoint
la scène devant un public friand des
chants traditionnels populaires
[Applaudissements]
2 c'est un homme
[Musique]
on
en corée le programme de réunion des
familles séparées depuis 1945 a repris
fin octobre difficile pourtant de croire
que les bonnes intentions des coréens de
paris puisse effacer 60 ans de haine
[Applaudissements]